robot bartenders are here to serve us
drinks ultimately destroy us the maker
shaker a new bartending robot consists
of automated arms that mix cocktails and
places them on a conveyor belt to be
carried across the bar to the waiting
customer however the goal isn't to do
away with bartenders who are still
needed to tend the machines the
co-founder of maker shaker and MIT
professor explained it started as
something to shock people in a tangible
way and to show them what the third
Industrial Revolution is all about the
first two installations of the maker
shaker can be found in Royal Caribbean's
cruise ship Bionic bar all right so it's
not here to replace bartenders accept
all bartenders are can be doing or
repairing the machines so bartenders are
basically becoming repairman so look
again we've talked about a little bit of
an open the pod bay jaw how Gauss zammis
so we already talked we talked a little
bit about how in 2001 before and I love
this future stuff this one struck me is
sad well I'm not even going to go to the
robots are gonna kill us think this is
what struck me as we're so disconnected
from humans that there is something to
do you ever have a bar at any time in
your life they used to go to and they
knew your name and you could sit down
and talk to the bartender because that's
God right well I listen if I want a
robot to make me a drink and not talk to
me I would just get married if they said
that was on a Royal Caribbean cruise and
I think if you're if they're gonna put
money into putting a robot on a cruise
ship it should be one to be able to wipe
up some norovirus all over them that's
where they should put those robotics in
yeah how about habit just to push the
giant fat people away from the buffet
for a few
some angry comments on that one what do
you think when you miss the the old
school cheers when you miss Sam alone
knowing your name when you came in I've
never experienced that most most amazing
things yes drink I do drink but not not
very much at all yeah okay but um yeah I
guess I don't know I don't know that's
that that's barely a blip on the radar
to me yeah I can't I want to get behind
this in some way but yeah I just think
it's we feel terrible if you cozied up
to a bar and there's a robot bartender
and you still couldn't get his attention
I will say this though no tipping ah but
you have to tip the guy who's fixing it
in the back that poor schmuck I think we
can make that rule right now no we're
not no that's why I feel sorry for our
the bartenders that have to fix it like
you know not only are you relegated to
be a being a bartender you got to get a
degree in IT you know take me a
bartender yeah you have to fix something
what do you think about the part about
just disconnecting us from humans
because that I do think I mean every
story that we do now is some other thing
where it's all about us looking in our
phones and all this stuff I wish you
know I wish that disconnected from the
humans thing was true cuz I'm not a big
fan of most humans yeah because of the
internet I interact with more people
every day now than I ever have in my
life yeah so I don't I don't really real
interaction forth on Twitter and I know
it's not just Twitter but it's real
interaction and and interestingly enough
yes because the stimulus comes from a
million different directions
conversations can get really interesting
in any number of formats but I find
myself you know here's the thing you
could be a Doug Stanhope fan you know
find yourself talking about Doug
Stanhope fan and Romania or you know you
can be Arcade Fire fan and find yourself
talking to somebody in China or you can
talk directly actually sometimes that
yeah exactly yeah so um I think in many
ways it what it's what it's doing is
it's it's eliminating geography from
tribalism that you now can create tribes
of like-minded people
that is you know the tribe exists
globally yeah and I think that's a
fascinating interesting part of social
interaction and I don't think we
interact with people less I don't I
think we direct with people more yeah
yeah I by the bigger idea there that we
do more I mean look I met both of you
guys basically through Twitter because I
do Kelly Carlin and which we all
connected through Twitter I've connected
with a zillion comedians that I love
yeah there's actually some really
meaningful friends in my life that I've
met through various yeah and yet at the
same time if you go to the supermarket
I'd find that half the time I'm trying
not to do it in which I'm staring at my
phone so that little communication that
little human moment that you might have
with the clerk or something that sort of
is disappearing why is that why do you
consider that equality interaction
whatever conversation we may have online
right maybe it isn't at all but you know
people like to be acknowledged you know
I try it now I try to be very present
with the clerk's cuz I was always
staring like yeah there's only there's a
little bit of sort of you know
politeness manners involved in that yeah
there's about be foreigners that I'd
lost yeah yeah no we're all guilty of
that a little bit but I do like how you
go to these places now a national signs
up we will not take your order if you're
on a cell phone you know kind of thing
which yeah this is the backlash to that
so that's kind of interesting
yeah it'll come out in the wash anyway
what do you think let us know in the
comments right down below